bold uh i want to call it a prediction
but uh i just
you know i have ideas sometimes okay and
i imagine a future
i like to look at everything that's
going on the variables and then try and
think as far ahead as possible the issue
with with predicting too far ahead is
that
the more variables you throw into the
mix the more
you know different the the the the
greater number of futures
she can perceive of course but i i
envision there's a possible future in
which
donald trump wins there is
some semblance of uh unity among
individuals in
rejection of this far left incentive
regular people are scared they can't
speak up their own opinions
that was the cato institute uh most
people do not hold these views it's
somewhere between eight and ten percent
according to a lot of these polls these
these far
progressive views and people hate cancel
culture so there's a lot of people who
are secretly not speaking up
i envision a future where we actually
come together
uh in a sense trump wins shocking the
nation and
you know ultimately we do end up in a
war with china and all of these things
that have happened from the riots
end up becoming an afterthought we've
got decentralized we
we've decentralized our economy remote
workers working in the mountains off of
you know where will the war take place
uh that's a good question pacific
international
uh the the south china sea like guam
like we're just fighting on guam
potentially well uh the south china sea
the atolls a lot of the conflict would
happen here
there but i imagine that depending on
who gets dragged into it and what to
what degree this this erupts
i first and foremost i would say this is
wild speculation sure looking
far into the future but most of the
conflict we've seen so far has been
between
in the south china sea with china you
know they've been accused of sinking
these fishing boats you know they've
been doing beaching drills no i'm not
so they're with this yeah so like
landing boats on the beach and running
in
and a lot of people think it's because
they want to invade taiwan they want to
seize control
and that could be a catalyst for you
know whatever this
thucydides war would end up becoming
between the us but we have all these
inadvertent things that have happened
because of the riots
that and it actually would help us out
if we went to war here's i think i i
don't know that i have anything
of interest to add to what you're saying
i don't think that's remotely an
impossibility
my big question i'm wondering is who is
more likely to have the riot's end when
they beca if they win the election
you can easily make the argument why
you'll be trump because now he's in a
position to stand in the tanks he's just
got the validation
but you could easily see b biden because
now you could say we have an adult in
the room now
well hold on tanks yes like sentence i'm
using that metaphorically but just
basically
a lot of law and order and i'd have the
national guard actually no no well no
he's doing something smarter oh he's
being smart now i'm just saying in terms
of november
like there's two scenarios and you can i
can make the case for either would be
the
bet one better to stop the riots from
happening trump uh the depositions the
feds have deputized oregon state police
did you hear this no i have not now an
arrest from an oregon state trooper over
these riders goes to the feds not to the
local d.a
oh that's so smart exactly trump nailed
it
nail you know with hammer while keeping
his hands clean yep
so a lot of people have been saying
insurrection act insurrection act and
i'm like man i don't know they'll use it
against them
of course so he's hitler he's an
authoritarian but not just that could
you imagine the troops coming in
and then the local uh government saying
get out yes
we're being occupied yeah so trump so
the dhs
deputizes the feds deputize the oregon
state police it's a local affair
but if the state police when they arrest
them the feds prosecute the problem was
the state police retreated
out of portland because every arrest
they made the d.a would be like you're
free to go
charges dropped so trump has figured out
a way to deal with the riots
well there you go what i thought he did
brilliantly was when he called out the
mayor of portland and he said you know
what
call me we'll style this so easily and
you wouldn't even believe it
because that tells everyone they're
either comfortable with this
or unable to stop it right and he's like
the offer is on the table
ball's in your court mr mayor i'm
respecting your authority and it's a
really the sm lori lightfoot this
chicago this genius
mayor of chicago she said well the riots
are happening
uh because we don't have gun control
lady you haven't had gun control in 2018
2019 2017. now all of a sudden it's
causing rioting how is
how is gun not going to have control
causing rioting it's amazing what straws
they'll grasp to try to
create some kind of reason for why
things are happening
because these things shouldn't be
happening how do these people keep
getting elected
like why is chicago been democrat for
what 80 years
well i think there's a there's a lot of
dynamics in cities where people just
culturally are going to end up voting
for the same thing over and over
uh and just expecting it's
unconscionable you're not going to vote
for a republican
and the republicans aren't going to
waste their time because you're still
going to have that city council that's
why i don't vote
well i don't i'm gonna i i i am gonna be
voting okay in november though
and uh the the surge of
intersectionality has freaked me out to
the point where i'm like
no i'll be completely honest trump
trying to withdraw the troops from
afghanistan i'm like
you know what i'll take what i can get
there's two things that are going to
fight this cult which i think are going
to be very useful
one is the more radical solution which
i've introduced which
uh it's the kind of thing is like you
throw out what the left does very well
is they throw out the completely crazy
version they settle for like three
quarters
defund the police you know it's like oh
my god it's crazy okay how about you
give us a b and c sure
as long as enough to defend the police
uh i think we should nationalize
all university endowments which are the
crystallization of prince
privilege there's nothing more
privileged than having a fancy ivy
league degree
and use that money for reparations have
you been following a will chamberlain on
twitter wolff chamberlain got that idea
from me
oh did he stole your idea he didn't
steal it he credits me
oh okay will chamberlain's my buddy head
of human events that's my idea
that's so great it sees the endowments
yes sees the endowments the other thing
that can happen in the short term
especially with startups is when you see
someone coming from an ivy league
you should look at that person with the
same stigma as someone who was gay in
the 1950s
this person is security risk you're
inviting something in your company that
you might not want
but that was wrong sure but now it's
right
well the the sjw stuff yeah but now it's
right to be discriminatory be like you
odds are this person has been trained to
be a member of this social justified
militia
look what happened to papa john's papa
john's was quoting someone
disparaging them yes he's saying don't
talk like this person who said this
that's terrible
you're fired he said can you believe
that this guy said kfc was correct
and he got away with it pressed and come
after him this is ridiculous and he got
fired from his own company
by the netflix guy no what happened he
was giving a seminar on words that were
offensive that shouldn't be on netflix
and he got and so this is hilarious his
story is so so amazing
he says a bunch of words someone in the
meeting complained to hr
they brought him in and said what
happened and he explained i was giving a
meeting explaining
these are the words we don't allow
netflix and then they're like what were
the words he said them and then the hr
people complained
he said the word in front of us what he
was telling you not to say it
but yeah but you're acting you're
describing rationality of fundamentalism
so this is what when you're you're
starting up a company
and you're looking at these resumes you
need to start looking at these as
examples of something to
fear and stigma and the the price the
value that they might add from coming to
lee college are
it's going to be decreasing in close as
opposed to cost you know what man i
remember when i was
a lot younger and when i was like a
teenager i i was catholic for a little
bit
just because i was a little kid you lost
your your helicopter yeah um
so so i went to catholic school up until
fifth grade time for the helicopters
and then when i was a teenager i became
very i don't necessarily want to say uh
atheist okay kind of agnostic but very
arrogant
oh yeah god yeah like the people and
read it totally totally yeah
but you're a fedora dumb you believe in
god okay
and uh right but i was you know so
morally superior yeah superior to people
but uh there there was like a concern
about this moral authoritarianism coming
from the right
yeah which is now predominantly on the
left and it's it's it's the exact same
thing
that's why i think it's funny you said
ascribing you know reason to a
fundamentalist faith
but these people are taking over to a
degree where
you know i remember hearing stories
about like what do i do when my family
is
ultra you know religious and they won't
listen to what i'm saying yeah
i have the same problem now in the other
direction i i i have
it's really interesting because uh the
the part of my family that isn't white
they love trump not all of them of
course but there's a lot of like you
know they're all like yeah trump's great
and the white people in my family my
extended family by the way are sjws
oh gosh they hate you it's the weird i
have no i i doubt it
i don't think they hate me but uh they
won't engage
so i've tried like commenting like hey
here's why i disagree with this weird
you know stuff you're saying
i didn't call them weird but like but
it's also your out group it's it's all
psychological because you're from the
other side and it's like it's
not even like look i'm talking about
like family members that i would go to
christmas with
and all of a sudden they're posting
nightmarish
white collectivist ideology right but do
you
see you're i don't think you understand
their perspective and i think it's
imagine if
like one of your cousins came and
started talking about bdsm and it's like
i get that that's what you're in
maybe it's a shrug for you but i'm
saying for some people it'd be like
why are you talking about this this is
at the very least creepy and weird
and i don't want to hear it normal
airports people don't think in these
terms right so that is what it's like
for them
for their faith when you're talking
about nuance regarding trump it's like
this is gross and not part of what i
believe it's not even that
it's like uh you know so i used to work
in nonprofit fundraising okay so i
i i was very good working for some of
these big companies at
communicating and like sort of opening
the doors into people like
in in in the sense that we could have a
conversation before they recoil and
sure so uh i actually did a lot of
trainings to teach people
how do you communicate with someone
who's not ideologically aligned with you
you need to build rapport before
anything so before you go up to them and
say you're crazy and wrong for believing
this stuff
you say something that's more uh rapport
building simply you have to play on
their turf not yours right you say
you know so a common technique is uh
where you're from
where are you from brooklyn brooklyn i
still i lived in brooklyn for five years
dude
man they got the best indian food in bed
style and it was this little hole in the
wall place i used to live in uh i like
middle of no stream you know merlin
nostrils this is people who don't live
in brooklyn that's how they talk i would
be running away sure sure but yeah i got
you no you're exactly right because then
it's like it's us
versus them right right so you create a
rapport yeah
i try i try saying things like on their
terms
racism is bad i'm so glad you're opposed
to racism
don't you think it's an issue that white
people are forming collective groups
yeah
and they immediately just there's no
logic there's no reason
and there's agree with me or get the f
off my page yes
yes yeah yeah um so they've been trained
to act this way thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell and we
are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all next time
you